any questions yes Angela congratulations
thank you Rachel Stern from
Entertainment Tonight
when we spoke to your hubby on the
carpet he said he was done filming every
moment but you know what he was in that
audience with this he couldn't help
himself he could not help himself
uncomfortable
[Laughter]
ungovernable that is what is it like
having your
having a cheerleader oh it's wonderful
we all need one
we all deserve one and you said
how meaningful this award is for you
because you saw people before you
knowing that there's a place for you
in in film in cinema on TV how surreal
is this moment and special knowing that
you know we always knew you could shine
but you know the critics are showing
that you're here and you're thriving and
look at that thank you I'm appreciating
and very grateful for uh with this
Accolade and for all the love that that
I've been receiving these last few
months
um it's a you know it's a delight it's
it's Wind Beneath Your Wings it's a
wonder congratulations
oh hi Angela oh hi you want to go
is it congratulations thank you on yet
another well-deserved award I'm Tanisha
Laverne Grant with blackin america.com
what song best describes what you're
feeling in this moment
Amazing Grace comes to mind wow and
that's all I wanted to know Amazing
Grace congratulations again thank you hi
Angela congratulations hey
I'm Larry with Fox News digital
um I know in your acceptance speech you
had mentioned the late Chadwick Boseman
you know talk about what he meant to you
uh he was he portrayed my dear son
um and I just adored and loved him as a
brother and a and a colleague no one
more
just such a light and such an
inspiration and such a leader a leader
on set in his quiet dignified way and
his immense Talent going before
we I miss him miss him dearly but as I
said he's with us in spirit even now
thank you so much thank you Angela here
hello how are you doing last time uh we
saw you it was a conversation at the
academy uh Academy and and then I wonder
what would it feel to get an Oscar
rather than this award oh let's just not
get ahead of ourselves
that would be uh that I'm sure that that
would be
the good good feeling of a lifetime
but uh yeah let's take our time my heart
rate is just starting to come back down
to normal now so I want to jack it back
up by thinking about that but that would
be amazing well that did you recall you
know how was it when you first realized
that you were dying in the movie right
and so I was wondering would you like to
relieve again in the next uh you know
movie that's definitely most definitely
so from your mouth to God's ears and to
Ryan cooglers Creative Soul you know or
the next writer of wakanda 3 yeah thank
you
I miss Bassett okay thank you one and
all oh yeah sorry just one last question
um it's been almost 30 years since
What's Love Got to Do With It And I
wonder if you can think back to yourself
then and all you've learned over those
last three decades
what would you tell yourself then and
how has the award season changed now
oh you know what I was sitting next to
Ruth Carter and I was telling her
um you know 30 years ago when I was
nominated for what's love I I don't
remember a any of this happening any of
this there was the Golden Globes for me
and the Oscar and there was nothing else
in between you know so it was it was
very easy going this this time uh it's
it's just been a lot a lot of excitement
you know a lot of going and a lot of
speaking and and talking and a lot of
love for
um for for the picture it's just
evidence of how far we've come from you
know my days as a you know young actor
here in Hollywood too
to now but uh you I would just tell
myself what I've told myself you just
hang on and hang in there
get up go to work tomorrow
because
when they fall in love with you
and give you things like this it's
because you put the work in
congratulations thank you
[Music]